>>> SO IN A NEW INTERVIEW PINK
FLOYD'S CO-FOUNDER ROGER WATERS
SAT DOWN WITH CNN'S MICHAEL
SMERCONISH TO TALK ABOUT THE
POLITICAL MESSAGING AT HIS
CURRENT THIS IS NOT A DRILL
TOUR.
THIS IS A CLIP.
>> THE CHINESE ARE TOO BUSY
ENCIRCLING TAIWAN AS WE SPEAK
INTO THEY ARE NOT ENCIRCLING
TAIWAN, TAIWAN IS PART OF CHINA
AND THAT'S BEEN ABSOLUTELY
ACCEPTED BY THE WHOLE OF THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY SINCE
1948 AND IF YOU DON'T KNOW THAT,
YOU ARE NOT READING ENOUGH.
GO AND READ ABOUT IT.
>> TAIWAN HAS NEVER BEEN PART OF
COMMUNIST CHINA.
JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS THIS
ABSOLUTELY RIVETING INTERVIEW
WITH ROGER WATERS IS CNN
POLITICAL COMMENTATOR AND HOST
OF CNN'S "SMERCONISH" MICHAEL
SMERCONISH.
I KNOW YOU ARE A BIG PINK FLOYD
FAN, AS AM I.
ROGER WATERS HAS THESE
CONTROVERSIAL SOME WOULD SAY
WILD VIEWS, BUT YOU ENGAGED HIM
ON THIS.
GO AHEAD.
>> IT'S NOT A HOT MIC, RIGHT?
THIS IS NOT A ONE OFF THAT ALL
OF A SUDDEN AN ENTERTAINER HAS
TO BE APOLOGETIC OVER.
HE'S CELEBRATORY IN HIS VIEWS
AND THERE'S A WARNING, JOHN,
WHEN YOU GO TO THE SHOW, WHICH I
DID SATURDAY NIGHT AND THERE'S
AN ANNOUNCEMENT THAT HE MAKES,
KIND OF TONGUE IN CHEEK WHERE HE
SAYS IF YOU'RE ONE OF THESE
PEOPLE WHO LOVES PINK FLOYD BUT
CAN'T STAND ROGER'S POLITICS
THEN I SUGGEST RIGHT NOW YOU EFF
OFF TO THE BAR.
HE VIEWS GOING OUT AND
PERFORMING AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PLAY HIS MUSIC BUT ALSO TO PULL
UP A SOAP BOX AND TO SPREAD HIS
POLITICAL MESSAGE.
MY POINT IS HE WELCOMES THIS
KIND OF ENGAGEMENT.
THERE WAS NO SURPRISE HERE WHEN
WE SAT DOWN THAT I WOULD WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THINGS LIKE TAIWAN,
THINGS LIKE CHINA, UKRAINE,
RUSSIA, ALL OF WHICH WE
DISAGREED OVER, BUT I THINK --
WE WERE KIND OF LIKE TWO GUYS IN
A BAR HAVING A COCKTAIL OR A
BEER AND DISAGREEING ABOUT
POLITICS.
>> LET'S PLAY THE PART WHERE YOU
SPOKE ABOUT UKRAINE WITH HIM.
>> IN THE CURRENT SHOW YOU'VE
GOT A MONTAGE OF WAR CRIMINALS,
ACCORDING TO YOU, AND A PICTURE
APPARENTLY OF PRESIDENT BIDEN ON
THE SCREEN AND IT SAYS JUST
GETTING STARTED.
WHAT'S THAT ALL ABOUT?
>> PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN?
>> YEAH.
>> HE'S FUELING THE FIRE IN
UKRAINE FOR A START.
THAT IS A HUGE CRIME.
WHY WON'T THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA ENCOURAGE ZELENSKYY, THE
PRESIDENT, TO NEGOTIATE,
OBVIATING THE NEED FOR THIS
HORRIFIC, HORRENDOUS WAR THAT'S
KILLING --
>> YOU'RE BLAMING --
>> WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
UKRAINIANS.
>> YOU'RE BLAMING THE PARTY THAT
GOT INVADED.
COME ON, YOU GOT IT REVERSED.
>> VERY INTERESTING.
HE TOLD YOU YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
READING ENOUGH OR IF YOU THINK
CERTAIN THINGS MAYBE GENERALLY
HE WAS THINKING.
I WONDER WHAT IS HE READING THAT
HE HAS SOME OF THESE POSITIONS?
OBVIOUSLY IT'S VERY
CONTROVERSIAL WHEN THERE IS USE
OF FORCE, WHEN THERE IS ANY
NATION THAT IS INVOLVED IN
ANOTHER WAR AND THE U.S. IS
PROVIDING A LOT OF WEAPONS, BUT
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF WHAT HE WAS
SAYING THERE THAT THE U.S.
SHOULD BE URGING ZELENSKYY
BASICALLY TO GIVE UP LAND TO
RUSSIA?
>> RIGHT.
WELL, I TOTALLY DISAGREE WITH
HIS PERCEPTION OF THE SITUATION
IN UKRAINE.
EVEN IF YOU ACCEPT THAT THERE
WAS SABER-RATTLING ON THE PART
OF NATO BY COMING CLOSER TO
RUSSIAN BORDERS, IT DOESN'T
EXCUSE THE BLOODSHED THAT
RESULTED FROM PUTIN'S INVASION
OF UKRAINE.
TO ME IT'S BLACK AND WHITE.
I ASSUMED THAT HE WOULD SAY THE
SAME THING.
BRIANNA, WHAT INTERESTS ME AS
WELL ABOUT ALL OF THIS IS THAT
THIS SHOW IS AN ENORMOUS AND I
WOULD THINK EXPENSIVE
PRODUCTION.
HE'S IN THE MIDST OF A TOUR OF
THE UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW AND
YET HE'S SEEMINGLY UNCONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT THIS COULD
HAVE ON THE BOX OFFICE AND
REMAINS TO BE SEEN, YOU KNOW,
WHEN THE TOUR IS OVER AND THE
RECEIPTS GET CALCULATED HOW DID
THAT ALL PLAY, BUT ROGER WATERS
DOESN'T SEEM TO CARE,'S GOING TO
GO OUT AND PLAY HIS MUSIC AND
SPREAD HIS POLITICAL MESSAGE AT
THE SAME TIME.
>> I THINK IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN
CHINESE OFFICIALS ARE ACTUALLY
RETWEETING A FULL CLIP OF THIS
INTERVIEW, PARTICULARLY THAT
PART OF HIM REMARKING ABOUT
CHINA AND TAIWAN.
MICHAEL, IT'S A TERRIFIC
INTERVIEW.
AGAIN, PEOPLE SHOULD GO WATCH
THE WHOLE THING.
I REALLY ENJOYED IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US THIS MORNING.